but uh yeah let's talk about some
current topics though
don't worry about just nostalgic trips
back to high school well we talk about
high school and [ __ ] so much but with
some [ __ ] funny stories yeah yeah
it's it's the prolonged
it's great memories people listening to
this who are still in high school won't
understand but once you're out of high
school
you'll understand you'll look back on
them man you sound like such a grandpa
saying that
you'll look back to your high school one
back in the day when we only had three
iphones
no but um what's the i guess the big
news
i don't have an attack on titan yeah
other than that of course everyone's
probably gonna be old news by the time
this episode is yeah everyone's [ __ ]
loving that but i guess
like some news that is more industry
driven
is the whole uh funimation and
crunchyroll thing right
sony buying out crunchyroll yeah
basically
having uh control of like most of the
big anime companies basically just
monopolize the western market i mean it
is
it is slightly worrying when you hear
that initially
yeah yeah that's a lot of market share
that sony has
yeah yeah like how would what at what
point would it be considered
a sony like i guess a monopoly if they
had like netflix right yeah i feel like
if
if they had crunchyroll funimation and
netflix
then then it'll be like then then it
would be like 99
yeah basically because basically i think
the only other company
is probably sentai filmworks who do high
dive
and is still going i know i'm still
going
sorry i didn't know i guess it's just
not available outside the u.s right so
it's
no it's available in the uk as well
isn't it yeah [ __ ] i didn't know that
but i
the the problem with high dive is that i
don't know how many
big like exclusive titles that they have
i mean how can you compete
yeah because the only the only thing
that i've watched like
the only big exclusive i've watched out
of high dive is probably legend of the
galactic heroes
and that's like that's like a [ __ ]
old old
no they're like the old or the og
they're the only servants that have
licensed
the og legend of the galactica wow and i
feel like
i don't know other how many other
exclusives they have
outside of that that i've never used
yeah because i know made in abyss i
watched that on
amazon strike back when that was the
thing remember
remember amazon strike
hasn't stopped buying anime now because
like i don't know what anime they're
getting anymore
the problem with amazon is that they buy
one big show they want
like last year they had vinland saga
yeah and the but the big problem with
amazon is that they sometimes get big
shows but
i don't know how to market it i [ __ ]
hate like watching anime on
amazon because they i don't know what
shows they have half the time right
like they actually have quite a lot of
anime but nobody knows about this
because
nobody [ __ ] watches anime on amazon
yeah not to mention that
i think just the general problem with
amazon is that they don't know how to
market it
yeah yeah like you find out usually
second hand from someone who's like oh
i watched vinland saga on amazon and you
just like villain saga is amazon what
the [ __ ]
i mean amazon actually watching it isn't
bad
like the play is really good and i don't
know like what [ __ ] conversion
they're using but like man it looks
crisp as [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah but god damn is it
horrible to use their [ __ ] platform
yeah yeah holy [ __ ] dude i'm like am i
renting this [ __ ] or am i am i
like streaming that's not clear half the
[ __ ] exactly exactly like i didn't mean
to rent bar right why am i why am i
watching car i try to watch [ __ ]
anime what the [ __ ] amazon [ __ ] and then
also
because now obviously we're using i'm
using amazon prime in japan
yeah amazon did that [ __ ] pro gamer
move of
being like um yeah no subtitles for
other languages outside of this country
yeah yeah yeah so if i want to watch it
i have to buy
prime which i have in japan and prime in
the uk or the us which is just [ __ ]
stupid does prime even work for you here
like uk prime work for you here no you
can't do that because it doesn't work
for me no no you need to use
you you have prime but it's really
japanese prime which doesn't offer any
english subtitles
yeah and obviously because they're like
we don't want people going on to other
countries and buying stuff which which
kind of makes sense but also why like
who cares
like like it's 2020 i don't know why
licensing laws haven't caught up to the
fact that
it's a global [ __ ] media right now
if you're going to limit it to one
country people are going to find a way
to you know
find other ways to watch it because
people are going to watch it whatever
happens
like most people like because i see
these threads on like on reddit where
they're like
bro if you buy netflix now in turkey you
can get it for like two dollars and i'm
like
but that seems like a lot of [ __ ]
effort like do i really care
about that much oh i'm glad that i i'm
glad that if i put all that effort in i
can save a whole four dollars yeah and
then
you've got to keep using a vpn when you
log in to do that anyway so you're
already paying for the vpn anyway
yeah and it's like oh it's not worth the
[ __ ] effort man like
do i really need this no i don't who
cares like i'll just i just want it in
the country that i'm in i don't have to
[ __ ] around with vpns
don't make this hard for me yeah and
amazon obviously made it they're like
how about how do we make it
as hard as possible yeah every single so
then no one used to
how do we make it so that you
accidentally buy a dildo instead of
watching villains
yeah that's basically like the amazon
prime experience do we have any like
i guess because there is very little
information about the whole like sony
acquisition right yeah i mean it's still
very early days now
wait maylene how much was it for how
much was because we don't know
in 2017 it was around 143 million 100.
that's right they did do that yeah yeah
143 for funimation
it's around 1.2 billion
[ __ ] wasn't it wasn't amazon only like
900 million
can you say that number again one point
1.2 billion dollars
that's more than gg crushing that's more
than amazon
bought which switch for you jesus christ
wow
oh my god the question is that i want to
know
funimation yeah yeah that's already
surprising but like the the biggest
question i have is like
it's like all right cool sony you have
all this [ __ ] money right to spend on
crunchyroll and funimation that's fine
but in my opinion it's just like what
are you gonna do with it
is the question i mean i guess because
when because i mean sony back in the day
bought the 95 of funimation or whatever
it was like
not gonna lie they didn't they didn't
really do much with it yeah i haven't
seen
much of a change from funimation i like
i don't know how well funimation was
doing back then right
but it seems like they've just gone gone
on business as usual now
yeah um 1.2 billion for crunchyroll just
kind of
sees how much they're investing in anime
i guess and yeah because
they must see the potential in the anime
industry to
get to like shell out this big of a
market i guess maybe they're willing to
throw that much money because they
realize that
there is a massive competitor now and
that is netflix
yeah yeah i mean i guess when you put it
into perspective like twitch was bought
out but that was like how many years ago
was twitch bought out by amazon like 20
probably around the same time that
sony first bought funimation no no no no
it was earlier than that was it i think
it was like 2016 right it must have
happened 2015. really
yeah but still what does it happen can
you google it yeah 2014
okay twitch was like the [ __ ] big
[ __ ] back then
yeah so twitch was 970 million but i
guess twitch 2014 i understand it really
makes sense twitch nowadays probably
worth like
five six times oh easily yeah yeah but
that that was i
i would say that you know which at that
point yeah comparing crunchyroll now to
twitch back then
twitch is still bigger i i would say i i
would say like twitch was like a hot
property because
everyone was expecting youtube to buy
twitch i remember back in the day where
it was like where it was just like yeah
everyone just everyone was like well
google is going to buy twitch that just
that's just a natural move
right yeah and it was a big surprise
when amazon kind of said jeff bezos was
like jk
i mean i'm a snippet i mean that's been
great for creators though that like yeah
yeah but that happened but yeah i'm
curious as to why
hmm do you have any thoughts on my why
this might be good or bad for anime fans
in general
i mean i'd say as a consumer it would
probably
be better because okay well more money
in the in the industry is always better
well it's not only that but
i remember i would say like the golden
age of like anime streaming was
remember when you could get every anime
you could conceivably want to watch
on one platform which was crunchyroll
back in the day and then
it kind of just like got spread out to
you know different streaming companies i
mean that was inevitable but it was
gonna be it was inevitable yeah
but i i mean the biggest thing i find
annoying isn't the isn't just the fact
that i have to pay for like
different streaming companies it's just
the fact that nowadays when i see and
when i go through the
when i go through an anime chart i
literally have no idea which anime is
going to be on which platform yeah
that's true that's right unless it
specifically says
like prime yeah example like like i just
want to
like log on to one service and be like
okay i just want to don't care how much
i would pay for this service i just
wouldn't want
one i just want to watch all the anime i
want to watch that one service
well it's it's like confusing because i
thought uh jiu-jitsu
is that correct yeah it was on was it
netflix no that was on crunchyroll
crunch but it is on netflix is it in
japan no in
in japan so it's really confusing living
in japan because i'm like wait who owns
what because japan and like
because obviously it's it's pretty much
japan rest of the world that's how like
yeah yeah
market works right obviously and it's
really confusing so i'm like wait
wait where do i watch it though i
realize netflix doesn't offer english
subtitles
probably for that reasons with a license
yeah right yeah [ __ ] it's a mess though
it is a mess yeah it's like how do i how
do i know where the [ __ ] i'm watching
what
and then everyone's just laughing being
like haha piracy you know like
yeah i mean i want to pay i want an easy
service
i mean i i want a convenience service
like i i'm willing to pay for a
convenience service which
for the longest time it was until it
wasn't
um and now it's like i you know i want
to support the industry but at the same
time
it's just like if i'm having trouble
finding which service has got which
anime
like i literally have to lis there there
is a dedicated search engine for this
which is like i think the name is like
because moe or something that's the name
of
the website but that's that's literally
a dedicated search engine
to search which anime is is on which
streaming style i know someone had to
make that yeah i know right that really
is telling
it's like this [ __ ] pre-order like
like a spreadsheet
like what are you getting what pre-order
[ __ ] what [ __ ] me
well then would you say then in that
instance that i guess like um
a full monopoly of the western market
onto one service is
a benefit i mean it's not then or not
monopoly though is it really
because netflix is right but that's what
i'm saying though like if for example
monopoly is always bad
yeah but that's what i'm saying but for
example if sony hypothetically
is like hey we want to like buy the
anime side of things from the netflix's
yeah right that would truly i would say
turn it into a monopoly at least in
terms of the western market
basically be a monopoly right that'd be
awful for anime fans yeah it would be
all for anime fans but at the same logic
that god was saying it would all be on
one platform too
i mean that's kind of like the kind of
like the [ __ ] disney argument now
isn't it right like
yes all my characters now are gonna be
in the mcu
yeah yay for monopoly right here you
know
right it's like with with the whole
disney [ __ ]
it's worrying because if everything's on
[ __ ] disney we only get disney-esque
products
right i don't want [ __ ] disney [ __ ]
all that i [ __ ] hate dessert that
reminds me of uh the other day when i
was streaming i don't know how true this
is so
take this with a grain of salt but
somebody was saying that there's a rumor
that disney might be acquiring shonen
jump
oh my god no no no no no please not
serious
i don't know how true that is fact check
this mailing yeah please can you can you
check this out check because he sounded
pretty [ __ ] convincing when
someone like people in the chat were
talking about but apparently
disney is thinking to acquire it because
they want to do
a collaborative thing between my hero
academia and
the mcu no no and i'm just in my head
that's got to be a [ __ ] troll yeah if
it is a troll then that's going to be
that sounds like a meme yeah if it is a
troll then i've fallen for the bait
but at the same time i wouldn't be
surprised if disney actually wanted to
do that
well because like think about it it's
like mcu superheroes
my hero superheroes it's a match made in
heaven according to disney right
right i can't wait for when like [ __ ]
all might shows up in avengers 5 or
something yeah
oh my god you don't see it all right
oh my god you know what that would mean
though the [ __ ] like
thanos versus goku memes would like
become real
again like take it with a grain of salt
it might be a troll joey's talking out
of his ass
i might be talking out of my ass i don't
know that just means like every mcu
conversation would
would end with but goku could be goku
could be captain america